we're waiting on a few people who are
having some parking issues um just want
to acknowledge some um substitutes today
uh representative Charlie Melvin is
subbing for Sandra panic and uh Steven
Pearson is subbing for Sheila side D and
Christina Dyer uh regrets she could not
be here but we do have Wednesday Adams
in her
place and uh it is questionable as to
whether there's a cousin it on the
fourth floor might
be all right I'm going to give this a
few more
minutes
to the costumes in our town the little
kids
yeah
represent open a hearing
on an amendment and this is a little bit
Terror Incognito for many of us but when
an amendment is brought forward that is
deemed non- gerine it must have a
hearing this is the hearing on Amendment
2351 on House Bill
now this the reason for having a hearing
is because it was posted in the calendar
and because it puts non-gain language
now into
play uh it will follow the rules of a
hearing in that the proponent the uh
Prime sponsor will get a chance to say
some things we will call on anyone who
after you've heard what the sponsor says
still wishes to testify so the chair
recognizes representative ball to speak
to Amendment
2351 on House Bill
185 thank you chairman
Pearson House Bill 185 has come before
this committee several times and with
several different amendments and at the
last one when we decided to retain it we
had identified oh do I need to go up
there
I
apologize a reminder that as the sponsor
of this and a member of this committee
you are will not be able to ask
questions of anyone who should
testify thank you chairman harison
um House Bill 185 has come before this
committee several times over the past
several months with several different
amendments this particular amendment is
addressing two issues uh or two concerns
that were brought before uh the
committee identified as two concerns um
one was the definition of fit parent and
the other one was adding in some
additional language to number two uh
section two number three representative
Molton and I worked on that language and
we came up with this amendment to
address it however after um more
reconsideration and getting some other
feedback uh we came to the conclusion
that this is still not ready for prime
time people are still debating it and as
such um I would prefer not to bring
forward this amendment and I would
prefer to bring forward something that's
a little more
simple are both representative molon and
I would like to do that thank you will
you take some questions from the
committee yes sir questions from the
committee let me ask you one that the um
Amendment you do wish to bring forth is
an amendment to the original Bill yes
yes it is Sir and it simply
changes two
phrases and could you speak to that
because it it will influence what we're
going to be discussing presently yes
chairman parison as a member of the
special committee to investigate Family
Court we looked into many different
areas of the family court and what we
found was at the Crux of the problem was
a differing of opinion of the phrasing
that is used in um the
original um law
which the number now escapes me I think
it was
341 64 I can't remember it how about
4611 thank you I'm sorry one a and I
only know that because I'm reading it
okay thank you um so what we found is
that although we um and most people
thought there was an idea that when
parenting decisions were made that it
was being done relatively close to a
5050 split we found that not all judges
were using that and that seemed to be um
where we were recognizing that there was
some concerns um being brought forward
and so that Amendment will now address
that particular concern with the hopes
that that will alleviate a lot of
um concerns by our
constituents and to what degree was
their buyin across the spectrum of
uh I'm blanking the word people who care
um well we did have uh judge king did
come and talk with us so he was one of
the people that gave us some advice on
the amendment um he gave that to the
special committee and um in speaking
with representative Molton and speaking
with our respective parties we had a
consensus in agreement that by doing
this in a smaller step and getting it
across a Finish Line would be in the
best interest of all involved so this
has buyin from both parties yes sir okay
any further
questions thank you representative
chairman yes may I yes you may I just
want to make sure I'm looking at the
right document so this this is the
2378 we haven't presented that yet oh
it's the larger one right now we're only
considering um
2351 okay and uh then the question was
in the relative to
the uh uh Equalization of parenting time
is that spoken for in the new the uh
latest Amendment yes it is and where is
it where does that I'm passing the other
amendment that is probably going to be
brought forward I'm passing this around
now so the members of the committee can
take a look at
it I'm not I'm not doing
that we're not going to address it I
just want
is okay thank
you uh we're not going to ask any
questions on the other Amendment but we
may look at it so
um we'll
know what Representatives ball and
Molton are going to be bringing forward
that's all we're doing we're not going
to ask questions on it I've been
informed well well Mr chairman just
having received the amend this latest
amendment I wouldn't be prepared to move
forward on any of this
because it's I just just received this
and I was focusing on the the amendment
okay we'll address that when we get to
the exact session on 185 right now we
are addressing the amendment 2351 as in
a hearing that's what we're doing okay
thank you Mr chairman okay any other
questions representative Bickford can
you point out what makes this amendment
non gerain no
well all right the clerk of the house
and the Speaker of the House said it is
non gerain but did they point out what
it is not to me okay they just said I
had to have a hearing so here we
are any further questions of
Representative ball thank you Mr
chairman yes there it is with a hand
thank you I'm sorry I just want to
representative clarify so that I have a
complete understanding at this point
you're asking that we not move forward
with
2351 which is this long one and that we
hold off until our exec and we talk
about the other one we're not voting
this is a hearing but she's asking that
when we get to the exec session
hopefully
soon this long Amendment will not be
brought forth okay thank you I
understand now it took a while to figure
this
out
okay thank you so much thank you now
given the fact of what you've just heard
if anyone wishes to
speak on an amendment that will not be
brought forth you have that right you
may not wish to do so because um for
reasons given so let me give you the
opportunity um uh Mr albrech if you wish
or you may wave
off
briefly
for the uh record Mr chair uh Dana alra
you've heard me here many times four
wonderful children I wish I could see
them just for our
audience uh if you could clarify we're
looking at
2351 which is not going to be brought
forth and what is the number that we're
hoping to
consider two three that will be
discussed during our executive session
right right right and during the
executive session is the committee able
to kind of mop up language from either
one of them if they think it's a good
idea or it's kind of up and down or one
or the other it is open for discussion
thank you thank you sir uh so in that
case I would just simply say that I
think
23 excuse me 2351 is fine language I
would be happy to see it
passed with that said I understand that
there were probably people in the state
who would oppose
this uh number of people earn a lot of
money you know
n and uh if we have to do what we have
to do to get something to get some kind
of shared parenting we have to do what
we have to do because I've gone seven
years and I'm a fit parent and while my
younger son is home sleeping off his
night at soup kitchen I haven't seen my
younger I've seen my younger three kids
probably 30 40 days total over the past
seven years M since my case started in
2016 so we've heard your testimony yeah
I uh just urg the committee to go
through the language of both of these
and do the best you can do thank you and
um any questions for Mr
alre thank you but before you go I the
chair wishes to thank you so much during
our last uh hearing session in June
because you helped prep Witnesses oh
because the credibility even if we agree
or disagree The credibility of how they
presented themselves was exactly what we
wanted and in part that was because of
your prepping some of them so thank you
so much thank you very
much chair recognizes Heather Desmond
you may testify or wave off your
choice good morning and thank you for
the opportunity to speak
today yeah you got to be real cozy with
the mic
I appreciate the opportunity to speak
today um as far as determining shared
custody um with RSA 461 A6 specifically
requiring the best interest of the child
to be taken into account when
determining parental rights and
responsibilities how is that determined
whether or not a parent is using these
tactics and who is it that investigates
these claims I have years of documented
proof um which was something that judge
Hall couldn't be bothered to take a
glance at there should be some type of
formal process for the petitioner that
is constructed by a forensic
professional um who are well versed in
the signs of Parental alienation where
in turn the said professional can make a
decision whether the the accusations
rise to the level of being heard by a
judge this process should allow evidence
attachments um this would eliminate a
judge's frustration in trying to
navigate through the hearsay and the he
said she said a judge would then have a
non-biased opinion of a qualified
professional as to any potential harm
being done to the children by one
parent's AC
um I have quite a few other points that
I think should be addressed um to start
from my own experiences some of these
issues are referencing a judge's bias as
to determining the the custody situation
according to New Hampshire state law the
neutral case evaluation protocol Section
3 C and D States ruling on motions or
making orders the evaluator shall not
rule on any motions nor make any orders
related to a case for which the
evaluator will be is or has been the
evaluator well judge poly Hall did
exactly this in my case my question here
is do we currently have a governing body
appointed to oversee this and ensure
that the Judicial Code of Ethics is
being upheld and may I interrupt you to
answer that question this is the chair
speaking sorry over here sorry that's
okay um I also chair the special
committee on the uh Family Division of
circuit court and we have been having an
awful lot of conversation with
administrative judges on
evaluations and supervisions which is
being done but in the opinion of some of
us could be done more and when there is
a particular judge about whom there's a
numbers numbers of concerns you know
everybody has a bad day or every judge
can have somebody who totally
misunderstands what's going on but when
there's numbers of concerns of the same
sort going forward we believe the
Judiciary will take take considerably
more notice than they have been this is
where we've been moving in special court
so I I think there is some answer to
your concern um you're going to be happy
I think or at least somewhat yeah I mean
I watched the last um meeting on
September 12th I believe it was um where
they were stating the judges are making
decisions based on what they consider
facts which often times are not the case
it's simply details that were documented
incorrectly whether they're later
corrected or not they remain f facts
that are strongly they strongly guide
future rulings and again in my case
these facts were obtained during a
neutral case evaluation where again
protocol specifically states that no
other fact carried over to the hearing
and future
appearances um and presented to the
presiding judge aside from participants
date and whether or not they came to a
resolution the judge Hall was present
and knew all the details that were later
understood to be fact and it determined
all of our future
hearings um I have a few other points of
contention um you you have this in
written testimony to us do you yes okay
good um since as I said we will not be
bringing this up this amendment up
nevertheless what you are offering I
think is very helpful both to this
committee and also to the special
committee so if we could have your
written testimony believe me we will
study it in this committee going forward
on this kind of issue and we'll
definitely be looking at it in the
special committee so thank you for
detailing this but uh you do not need to
read all the rest of it um if you've
made a good impression on me I don't
know about the rest of them but if you
could uh give to representative Bickford
your your copies um when when we're
finished and would you take questions
sure any
questions was that a
hand that's
that's I yeah I'm I'm well yeah I'm
needless to say I'm jealous um thank you
so thank you thank you for coming if you
would make sure that we all get a copy
of this this will be very
good chair recognizes uh representative
post asked to speak for two minutes you
may testify if you wish or wave
off all
right
good
are we on now we're
on good morning I um am Lisa post for
the record uh representative Lisa post
from liboro I am the prime sponsor of
185 and um I have worked with uh
representative ball and representative
Molton and uh working through uh some of
these changes I do like um the amendment
2351 H I think it's very
comprehensive uh
however sad it is um that we can't
present something comprehensive because
we know we can't get it through and I
appreciate everybody's hard work and
consideration um in trying to make it a
bill that is passable so while I do like
like this bill I will
um be happy to be in the executive
committee and hopefully have a bill that
can pass so thank you very much thank
you politics is the art of the possible
unfortunately sometimes but thank you
representative um anybody else on the
committee wish to say anything uh this
is not a um exact session it's a hearing
so before we close the hear he in
anybody else on the committee wish to
address
this okay seeing there is not then I
close the hearing on
2023-24
51h and at
10:00 3 minutes we will start our
executive
sessions
and I open the executive session on 10
retained bills for the house children
and family law
committee this Begins the executing
session on House Bill 120 the chair
calls upon himself for a motion I I move
itl second okay it has been moved and
seconded this is a bill that we kept
regarding the cunu center because we
didn't know at the time whether we would
need it as a vehicle to build upon or
change or add or whatever as it turns
out the new Youth Detention Center which
will be built 300 yards from my house in
Hamstead if there was any a nimi
involved I'm it um this bill is no
longer needed so it is worthy of I any
discussion the motion before us is House
Bill 120 itl moved by The Chair seconded
by the Vice chair with the clerk please
call the
role chairman
Pearson
yes sorry representative long
yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson is yes where are you oh there you
are okay I did not see you thank you
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
representative grman yes representative
LC yes representative patrino will be
voting yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond yes passes unanimously any
objection to
consent I've already had the committee
report drawn up here it is oops that's
mine this is
yours all right that ends the exec uh on
120 and I now open the ex executive
session on House Bill 306 which has to
do with
reunification therapy and representative
Raymond for a motion on an amendment
please thank you Mr chairman um I move
OTP on the amendment to 306 do you need
the amendment
number yes 20 at the amendment number is
H and is there a second yes the chair
has himself down to do that so I second
that and would uh representative Raymond
you please speak to your Amendment
motion okay thank you so this bill um
initially working with the sponsor um
the intention was to um protect both um
parents and children going through
custody cases um by making sure that
judges are giving consideration towards
picking uh Mental Health Counselors who
are covered by the parents health
insurance so we're not having um these
outof Network providers ordered and
parents having thousands of dollars in
bills that they can't afford um and then
she also was concerned about um judges
ordering certain um reunification
therapies that um don't act in the best
interest of children um so we needed to
get to a little bit of a a definition of
what what kind of services are we
worried about um and so we're worried
about Services um that as a condition
for participation um issue as a as a
matter of course no contact orders
transfer of custody threats Force um
coercion verbal or physical abuse or
isolation from the child's community and
so we're this bill is telling judges
that those are not appropriate Services
uh during child custody um
Arrangements any questions from the
committee to the amendment
sponsor you've got copies of it in front
of you I hope everybody
yep Mr chairman representative Bickford
may I ask does this the shall not order
family reunification treatments
programs
so uh including but I'm trying to
understand it so is that out now or is
that on certain conditions like if the
insurance covers it or if the person
wants to pay for it themsel or so it
says the that part of the bill says that
um the the the court shall give due
consideration to selecting a counselor
who is recommended by the parties and is
a participating provider it doesn't
prohibit the court from ordering a
provider who isn't accepted by the
insurance um but it asks them to look at
the insurance providers first because
there might be a situation where both
parents agree we want this person to
provide the the treatment to our family
but they're not in our Network and the
judge can say yes to that um the idea is
to keep the judge from kind of going off
on their own and choosing somebody over
the objections of the parents who also
they can't afford um and then as far as
reunification therapies the judge can
order reunification therapies provided
that they don't utilize these harmful
practices utilize what these harmful
practices that are listed in the bill so
it's did you spell that word what
practices harmful harmful yes oh
harmful than I guess I guess I've been
in New England too long now um so um so
for example um there are reunification
therapies Who as a matter of course
remove the child and place them in a
camp out of state um that's their
practice um there are um reun re
reunification therapies that that
utilize verbal and physical abuse or
isolating the child from their supports
as part of their practice with the idea
that this will help somehow breaking
down the child will build up their
relationship with the other parent um
and you know it's not in the best
interest of child of children to have
their Spirits broken in an attempt to
repair a damaged relationship we ought
to be using some more evidence-based
practices than
that okay thank you yep any other
questions from the committee to the
amendment Prime
sponsor seeing none we have before us
the amendment
2306 to House Bill
[Music]
306 moved by representative Raymond
seconded by the chair and would the
clerk please call the
role jamman Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will be voting yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Molton yes
representative Raymond yes unanimously
passes 16 to zero now before us is House
Bill 306 is amended by Amendment
2023-24 6 representative Raymond for a
motion I'm sorry I've lost track of what
we're doing so you need another mtion I
need a motion now for the bill as
amended to pass oh yes okay I move OTP
on the bill as
amended otpa thank you m and the chair
will second that any further disc
discussion seeing none the clerk please
call the
role representative chairman Pearson yes
representative long yes representative
disimon yes representative bfid yes
representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative m
Vin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative L yes representative
Patrina will be voting yes
representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond yes unanimously passes 16 to
zero any objection to
consents representative Raymond please
get the committee report to the
clerk
that ends the exec session on House Bill
306 and I went a little bit out of order
because I put the file in the wrong
place uh coming around is that wonderful
testimony that we heard just a few
minutes ago
um and uh everything is good on it
except I don't see the
person's name who submitted it is it at
the top yeah oh sure it
is good thank you so much Miss
Desmond
sorry
18 this was on 185 correct this was
testimony on the amendment to
185 yeah that's a keyer I want to keep
some of these for our other
committee
um
okay begin the exact session on house
Bill 185 the chair recognizes
representative ball for a
motion chairman Pearson I'd like to put
forward a motion to
OTP the amendment 2023 2378 h on House
Bill 185 and everyone should have that
that was passed around this is the
amendment do I have a second
representative Molton yes
so it has been moved and seconded that
we consider the amendment
yes yes good just want to
check and it's not very long take a good
look at
it
representative Ball please speak to
the motion on the
amendment this motion goes back to the
very beginning of the house bill 185 and
it simply changes two sections of the um
RSA
461 it will replace the words frequent
and continued continuing contact with
approximately equal parenting time in
two sections and why is that a good idea
461 what we have found in our
investigation through the special uh
committee investigating family court is
that we have a very small number of
Judges who are not interpretate they do
not interpret frequent and continued
contact as as equal to 50/50 as possible
therefore parents and families that are
going into different cour houses are not
being treated equally because the law is
being read differently so we would like
to formalize and make sure that all
judges um are on equal footing and all
families get a fair um and Equitable
considerations in the cour houses any
further questions yes representative
molon thank you Mr chairman um I I've
been back and forth about this bill all
week and this is not a decision to take
lightly um that being
said the language saying frequent and
continuing contact is very problematic
because it is not it is very vague it is
not it doesn't say how it's going to
look for a particular family which I
understand is for that's for the judge's
discretion however that's when we get
into situations where
if one party interprets it that oh
frequent and continuing contact just
means phone calls then the other party
can utilize that too and we do have
parties out there that will weaponize
this against the other person who will
interpret it according to how it's
written but then how they're taking
those words to mean and because our the
language doesn't have anything further
to direct the how the judges are
supposed to order it um then that's
where we run into a lot of problems and
we've we've heard multiple testimonies
of different problems that have been
that have gone through the courts so
that and that includes my own um but I'm
not here to talk about my own situation
I'm also talking about like all the
testimonies that we've heard
so that being
said then there's then I yesterday I
heard testimony where this would
be problematic
for families that are going through
abuse and I recognize that domestic
violence has a lot of of of problems
legal problems that are that come along
with
that however I told the person who was
telling me this that the the purpose of
this
the the changes to the language is
to put boundaries up on the on what the
other person can utilize for harm so in
other words
if if one person is interpreting
frequent and continuing contact as oh
that they you know they can live with
this person but but then I can just do
phone calls the other person can use
that too because if there's not language
saying that only one person can use it
then both parties can use that
language is everybody is that so that's
why you support the amendment you
co-sponsored so I just hang on but then
that's hang on Mr chairman H hang on Mr
chairman did you work on night last
night no I didn't this is me and my
natural I going to say you're very
coherent and that's that's always good
so my point is that if we if we can stop
the we ization of the language because
people are interpreting it willy-nilly
so to speak then then that is good and
that is protective in my opinion so I I
would love to hear what other people
would think
about changing the language and we are
about to do just that the chair
recognizes the vice
chair thank you Mr chairman um yeah I
think approximately complicates it more
uh approximately Eco par morning time in
my mind has nothing to do with phone
calls um at least continued contact
phone calls would be a contact so I can
see judges being more perplexed on
approximately um than the frequent and
continuing
contact
um I believe they're going to have their
own opinions on what approximate
is so if we're looking to
narrow um you know the difference in
that they're thinking um I don't I don't
believe this really does
it would the either sponsor care to
speak to that yes sir go
ahead I believe that the word
approximately is in there because we
cannot rip a baby in
half and that is by saying equal
parenting time that is what we are
attempting to do so we have to realize
that there are times when it way may not
not be exactly 5050 it might be
4951 for the simple reason once again
we're trying to get that weaponization
out because if a child let's say they
get to stay home from school one day
because it's a holiday now they have
three extra quotes parenting hours with
that parent and the other parent can
then turn around and say well you owe me
three hours or an hour and a half or
they're going to start dissecting this
down so small so if we say approximately
equal it in most Minds as is today that
we're thinking 5050 that's what our goal
is but we know we can never accomplish
Perfection and I think approximately
equal and it does say parenting time it
does not say contact it's parenting time
um so I I think that
addresses that we're not talking just
phone
calls Mr chairman may I the hand in the
corner
were you raising your hand or stretching
I was but I can well that's all right I
can do this representative Raymond go
ahead
please okay thank you um thank you Mr
chairman
so I I think that
um in modern times we all agree that um
kids do best when both parents are
actively involved in their lives and
they have a a healthy relationship with
both parents um I'm wondering how this
change um interacts with things where
there are cases of abuse or neglect but
then also um how it interacts with
families who um have significant um
physical distance between the parents or
perhaps the parents live in different
school districts um I'm thinking of like
my daughter's best friend uh her parents
are divorced and for a while it was
50/50 but now that they are entering
into high school like the 5050 is not
working for their family because of the
number of activities and stuff both
loving wonderful parents um how does
does this give judges the flexibility to
be able to make determinations based on
individual um children's
circumstances did I does that make sense
representative ball you wish to address
that yes if I can address that I think
what what this does it's not that it
gives the judge it gives the parents the
flexibility to create their own
parenting scheduling that works for them
um for their individual family this is
is not something where it says you have
to do this it's just saying that the
judges are going to support it so it
can't be weaponized to keep a child from
a parent but if parents mutually agree
that for their family unit it works best
to do it another way then that is the
way it is done it is the parents who
should be creating their parenting um
plan I think I heard somebody request on
this side of the room did I no yes
no yeah that was me yeah represent
Perez thank you for allowing me to speak
of course um with all my respect
um I feel very um uncomfortable when
when it comes to this amendment because
that uh co-sponsor of this amendment
already said that you know uh this had a
little bit to do with her personal even
though that she said that she's not
going to speak about her personal but it
bothers me when someone involves her
personal life when introduce something
you know we we here to uh work for the
community not for our personal
um uh
agenda would you wish to speak to the
Amendments and that's why I'm saying you
know I I would love to to say you know
that um parents you know should
to have the opportunity to be with the
kids and then in some cases parents you
know they're not El or they should not
be have
5050 because
uh people sometime get divorced because
of use relationship and and then
sometimes parents should not or one one
of the parties should not should not
have the equal time when the other
person was do have do you it um
bigon representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman we this is something that we've
um gone over a lot within the special uh
committee that we've been working on and
one of the things I do want to point out
is that the court has been very clear
there are three judges that have not
necessarily been you know having this
presumption or whatever that they would
work with these particular judges to do
that I I think when we take something
like this and put it into law we
have there's no easy way to say you know
that divorce is never easy split it
sharing custody is never easy um
something has happened that makes it no
longer feasible to live together when we
put something like this in law where we
say approximately equal parenting time
even though this is trying to kind of
soften those
edges it I believe it's going to create
many more issues than the couple that it
would solve um you know even from we had
somebody testify that you know trying to
say okay we know we say it's good
parents but there's approximately equal
time and a parent has to literally say
so I can't have my kid like 50 for you
know half the time I can't so it
actually because of this so then you
know there's all these there's all these
different issues with this so I think in
trying to solve a problem for a few and
and by the way there are a few then
those are valid concerns um where maybe
there hasn't been abuse there's just
been a misunderstanding by the court but
by trying to solve a few things this
particular language whether it be in
abuse cases whether it be in cases where
parents just have to work a lot more
than the other one we are complicating
an already complicated situation we
making it more complicated would lines
14 to6 mitigate that by saying if it's
not in the best interest of the child
the court may make findings right uh
supporting the order I think that's a
way out of so that's one of those those
um maybe an extra seat Bel in certain
areas the problem is specifically so you
know this isn't the case I mean there
are a lot of different reasons for each
one of the things but if we're talking
about um let's talk about abuse cases
because a lot of the ones that we're
hearing there are either allegations of
abuse or whatever else when something
you have something like this in law that
says approximately equal parenting time
what that does to people who are in
abusive situations which it's a huge
step to say I'm going to go from being
married to this person where I'm in a
house I can kind of have an eye you know
on what's going on because even if
somebody doesn't realize they're an
abusive situation but they're in this
relationship they do know they're
protecting their kids from certain
things so there are many cases in
abusive situations that to separate from
that parent is one thing but the Fear
Factor that comes into that is how much
much time will the child be with them
abusers will use this saying I'm going
to get that you know 50% of the time A
lot of times they do say I'm going to
take the kids away from you completely
um that's that's not going to happen
because we do have judges looking at
this and they have the discretion right
now to make sure that they you know are
doing what's the best interest for the
child this something like this in law
will keep people in situations they
should not be staying in and that's my
fear for the couple situations that we
could fix that are definitely innocent
we are going to hurt a lot more people
representative
ball I have not seen any data supporting
uh respectfully um I have not seen any
data supporting um that assertion I do
know a personal cases where people
actually stay in relationships because
they are afraid they were going to get
less than 50% of the time and could not
leave their child um could not leave
this abusive situation because
traditionally the court courts would
have ruled in favor of I hate to say it
but the mother um luckily our courts are
now um recognizing that fathers and
other um and
mothers um equally love their children
and they should have equal access they
do not need to prove that they are fit
parents they are fit parents unless they
are proved otherwise um and I believe
that having this it just says that you
support it I believe that if parents
were told going into their divorce case
that don't bother trying to get full
custody in a situation where there is no
abuse don't bother asking for that
because the judge is going to support
5050 it's going to alleviate a lot of
tension a lot of anxiety a lot of fights
um and it allows the family to move
on obviously there is a carve out for
when we have child abuse and when we
have domestic violence that's all
already in the law but in looking at the
majority of cases which involved loving
families whose parents just no longer
want to live together that we need to
allow that family to separate and allow
equal access to both parents and for the
best interest of the children thank you
representative Greg I would like to
point out that in the majority of the
cases where they do have loving parents
they do not have um also the argument on
what's going to happen with custody so
in the majority of cases you're right
where they have two loving parents they
also do not have uh disagreements where
any of this needs to be
changed representative ball thank you
chairman person with all due respect we
just spoke of that there are three
judges that do not start with 5050 so
they at their own discretion decide
where they're going to and divide up the
custody so therefore there is no quote
guarantee or anything going in and it's
not fair for families have a crapshoot
based on whether or not they get those
three judges a bigger concern is we are
now bringing in more judges to the
family court if those judges are then
mentored by the three judges who have a
different mindset we have now multiplied
our problem and it's going to be
happening in every courtroom I still
believe that if Justice is blind then
every family under similar circumstances
should walk into every single courtroom
in New Hampshire and come out with the
same results there shouldn't be a
crapshoot for parents and often times
that's what I'm hearing from my
constituents is oh my God I don't know
which judge I'm going to get and they're
being um told by their attorneys or if
they're working prosay it is it's all
going to matter what judge you happen to
get and that's just not fairness it's
not
Justice anyone else wish to speak on
this representative Molton um I mean
representative ball thank you Mr
chairman
um representative ball hit a lot of the
points but we're just not seeing that
there's already a lot of complications
for if someone's going to leave an
abusive situation whether it's Financial
or you know the the fear uh aspect or
you know the violence there's all those
already exist I'm not necessarily
convinced that this is going to add to a
problem that's already happening what we
actually need to solve that problem is
more
uh law enforcement getting involved in
civil issues as opposed to you know just
telling them
to calm down or whatever you know they
end up saying to them
also um I'm not legislating based on my
uh personal situation thank
you representative
Bickford thank you Mr chair
um well 20 years
ago there's a fellow named ol dunberger
that came here and told us about Sweden
he came from Sweden he he says I can't
believe we're even talking about this he
says we automatically do equal do
equality in Sweden 20 years that was
before 20 years ago they did it there
and and I filed a bill it was called HB
529 in 2005 very very similar to this
started off with uh approximately or
equal time that should be the goal
poost and uh we went through five
amendments I think it was five anyway
and representative walls I don't know if
anybody knows representative walls
anymore she was near that long ago she I
think she chaired this committee for a
while okay and uh so she came up with a
bill that said comparable that was the
word she used we went and it went to the
Senate it passed 14 to zero from this
committee and when it went to the the
Senate um they had changed it which
which disappointed me Senator Foster and
I were worked on it together but they
had ended up changing it to be may be
the court may do comparable and so we
ended up going to committee conference
and uh I was one of those that that
killed it but I know one of the Senators
came to me and he says but at least
you're getting some language in there to
get started with and that's where we are
again today 20 years later
I I'm willing to pay pass it just to get
started again
anything thank
you representative
Greg oh
yes Vice chairman
long thank you Mr uh chairman um I get
coming quickly but to think that the
word approximately is not going to get
us the same people coming with the same
issues it
is is not a is is not a fact I mean in
my opinion the crapshoot is still
approximately um so it it you know and
looking for
ammunition I'm traveling so I I can't
have approximately equal parenting time
and uh my ex tells my kid your dad has
an expectation of approximately equal
parenting time he didn't want it
so talk about ammunition you know this
is building up more ammunition to think
that this is going to take care of the
problems we've been hearing um they in
my opinion just doesn't do so thank
you okay let's dra start drawing to a
close here representative
B in the states that have passed you're
welcome I'm sorry thank you chairman
Pearson in the states that have already
passed uh equal parenting all the DB dat
has shown domestic violence has gone
down the animosities within the court
has gone down and the parents move on in
a better healthier fashion um with
regard to the word approximately I I as
I said there's no such thing is exact
and that was why as a committee we
actually disgu we chose to use the word
approximately quite a while back um the
fact that we're changing the contact to
Parenting Time I think is a big
difference it makes it very clear this
is parenting time it's not FaceTime it
is parenting time
and thank you very
much anybody who really hasn't brought
wants to bring up a point that really
hasn't been brought up otherwise we're
just repeating
anyone what oh representative deimon
thank you Mr chairman I I think that one
of the things that hasn't been brought
up is the human aspect of a very
difficult time in a family's
life approximate is the best we do
unless you specifically split the child
or the
calendar exactly
5050 the rest according to Webster's
Dictionary is
approximate that's why the word is being
used The Human Condition is and the
human's lives are you cannot always
split 12
12 you cannot always split exact so
equal is the approximately the best we
can
do and that's why approximately equal
parenting
time
time is the best option for New
Hampshire's
families thank you Mr chair
welcome all righty motion before
us is on House Bill 185 the amendment 20
23-23
78h move by representative Ball seconded
by representative Molton we are voting
on the
amendment with the clerk please call the
role jamman Pearson
yes representative long no
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes represent
resentative Melvin yes representative
Pearson
yes Representative grman no
representative LC no representative
Patrina will be voting no representative
Perez no representative Greg no
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond uh
no
9-7 9-7 in favor the chair will
entertain a motion from representative
ball thank you chairman Pearson I make a
motion that we
pass um house
build 185 amended by amendment by
Amendment
2023 2378 H I'll
second
um
right I'd like a Democrat if I could
interested and you still interested a
good
deal I'm
sorry I'll I'll resend my second and
hand it over to my friend representative
Simone May seconded it's fine it doesn't
matter
okay make sure you generous at uh candy
tonight
okay you came in you didn't get I like
Snickers oh taking care of good all
right we want 50 50 here on this candy
the motion before
us House Bill 185 amended by Amendment
202 3-23
78h moved by representative Ball
seconded by representative D Simone uh
would the clerk please call the role on
the bill as amended chairman Pearson
yes representative long no
representative
ton representative bfid representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes representative Sten Pearson
yes Representative grman no
representative LC no representative
Patrina will be voting no representative
Perez no representative Greg no
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond No
9-7 9 to7 the motion passes and would
representative Ball please uh write out
the committee report for the
clerk somebody want to do a Minority
Report would somebody like to do a
Minority Report yeah I'll do the
Minority Report thank you very
much
okay I
do
welcome please pass this down to the
vice chair to the vice
chair
okay open the exact session on House
Bill
455 relative to creating a new state
cause of action and special findings for
Abused neglected and abandoned children
seeking special immigrant and juvenile
status under federal law Prime sponsor
represent
tersi uh the prime sponsor had requested
the committee itl this representative
Greg for a motion I make a motion that
we itl and representative Bickford for a
second all right
discussion go
ahead based on the prime sponsor um you
know and kind of I think this had the
best intentions whenever they first
filed it but as far as uh with what's
going on federally with the laws and
stuff this is just not you know it's it
could be making more problems but it's
not meeting what it was supposed to meet
so I um fully support recommending that
we itl
this any further
discussion you know having been here a
little
while good things with good motivation
start out and along the way we learn
things and uh I know once I asked a bill
I put in please itl it uh they were very
happy to do so so um I'm sure this
subject will come back and it needs to I
think any further discussion motion
before us is to itl House Bill 4 55
motion made by representative Greg and
seconded by representative Bickford with
the clerk please call the role chairman
Pearson yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Petrino will be voting yes
representative
Perez yes represent resentative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond yes 16 to zero any objections to
consent representative Greg please fill
out the
paperwork concludes the exec session on
House Bill
4555 and now the chair
opens um an exec session on
471 an act relative to final disposition
hearings in divorce proceedings the
chair makes the motion of
itl keep it down I'll I'll second and
the vice chair seconds it we can
understand why people want closure in a
divorce case it's emotional people want
to get on with their lives they would
like to put in their calendar the date
of the final disposition
but to demand a final hearing be
scheduled at the time temporary orders
in a divorce proceeding are issued is
not really realistic first of all every
case has its own issues and being early
in a case we may not know how long the
proceedings will take we hear from some
the demand that the court accept every
piece of evidence
proferred yet we also hear from people
that some parties keep churning by
demanding more than more than more which
is more likely to happen if the court
accepts e Peach of evidence offered how
can you plan a terminal date if that
kicks in sometimes emergencies come up
in court an emergency hearing on
something that is extremely urgent and
by protocol everywhere that bumps
everything else down and that may mean
your your final uh disposition date will
not be held even if everything else is
going smoothly also the bill to me seems
to be a bit contradictory to itself on
the one hand it demands the final
disposition hearing be
scheduled but then it says it may be
rescheduled for
cause for Just Cause what are the just
causes doesn't Define them it could mean
any judge who has a cause believes that
judge to be just I don't think judges
believe themselves to be unjust so who
determines and what is the
determination and finally though the new
budget is funded six more Circuit Court
judges it's still not enough to move
things at a reasonable Pace we know that
a lot of the testimony that we heard was
that those six new judges are going to
help
somewhat but the um study committee
outside stud study committee determined
there needed to be at least 20 new ones
we've made a good start we're hoping
more will be funded in the next budget
but we have gotten
six and things are moving slowly because
there's too many things to
move as chairman of the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit Court I've had several
conversations with the honorable David
King chief administrative judge of the
Circuit
Court they agree
that there are some judges who may have
a weak spot here and
there judges will be helped along in
such areas and if it seems a judge or
two is in need of some continuing
education in the matter of better
scheduling I have sensed in my private
as well as public hearing contact uh
contact with the
judges um they will be looking more at
judges who seem to be outliers in terms
of how they handle this or that so that
if there is a judge that really doesn't
seem to quite know how to work a
schedule there will be some help
provided continuing education so for all
of those reasons um while certainly
people would like to have a date um I am
moving this bill in expedient to
legislate
anyone
else
right I know I hogged all the good
points yeah
sorry
yes your back lit thank you Mr
chairman there you are just we oh the
sunlight's behind me I thought it was a
you know
an well what we had discussed earlier in
the year was that the if we want to just
move some of these cases along the
solution is not to put a end date right
away the solution is to hire more judges
um
because the the clog up is that the
cases take such a long time and we just
don't have enough judges to hear all the
cases in the time frame that they want
to be heard so um
that we're recognizing the same problem
but we're just looking at different
solutions seeing no further discussion
the action before us is um House Bill
471 the motion is inexpedient to
legislate moved by the chair and
seconded by the Vice chair would the
clerk please call the rooll chairman
Pearson yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative L yes representative
Patrina will be voting yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Molton yes
representative Raymond yes 16 to Zer any
objection to
consent seeing none on to consent I
think I've given you my committee report
uh I'll be happy to transcribe it onto
the form and sign it if you
wish sends the executive session on
471 there was a fiscal note to that Mr
chairman I don't believe
you and there was another one yeah the
question the question arises sometimes
if
indeterminable VI means it cannot go on
consent so let me just say that if it
may go on consent that's where it's
going and if it may not go on consent it
isn't going on consent how's that
huh and that way you can you can find
that out
and ah because it's itl
aha this is a continuing ed moment here
what's that to be how does it feel to be
perfect I don't know if I have a get
there I'll let you know approximately
approxim
approximately but not
equally
okay where are we we've just did that
one all right so Mr
chairman it's me yes hi you hi hi thank
you for allowing me to speak um with all
my respect I have a lot of respect for
you and and with all the respect I just
want to mention something that bothers
me early today I raised my hand to
speak and I was ignore no you seen is
this is not the first time that it
happened I just want to mention that
with all my
respect I have the right to
speak and then this is not the first
time and then you ignore and then you
ask who was raising the hand to speak
when my hands was and then my microphone
was on like I say with all my respect I
I I would love to have their son respect
but back to me when I I asked to to be
able to ask a question or
speak I'm going to go out on a limb and
wonder if when I don't see
representative Raymond I am treating her
with disrespect or like you this morning
I didn't see it and you were called
upon and you will be called upon you may
not be called upon next I may miss a
hand or a voice here or there
but you will be called
upon opening the exec session on House
Bill
475 requiring rules of any and all
evidence to be accepted in Family Court
which the respondent believes will be
favorable to his or his or her case um
the chair is offering ing as an
amendment
2324 and I'm
passing that
around
four six
seven I think that's
enough I got a few more if it's
not
do everybody have
Amendment
everybody very
short oh you're you're short you need
another
copy okay
um
service
no I don't
know
I just passed out Amendment
2324 the chair moves it and um do I have
a second on that second representative
long thank you let me speak to this
amendment
[Music]
um
this is the
book called Rules of Evidence
from
Hampshire it looks tattered and torn
torn and so on not because I bought it
in a used
bookstore but because I've read it four
times with the
footnotes with the subheadings with the
references to those law books over
there and uh the original Bill
40475 states that the right to present
evidence shall not not be limited by
anyone in charge or even limited by The
Rules of
Evidence does the sponsor really mean
that a trial could go on and on and on
because the judge would not have the
power to stop someone from keeping on
admitting evidence
forever whereas The Rules of Evidence
give
encouragement to the judge to say
this
proferred rule this proferred piece of
evidence does not enhance the case it's
just
repetitive it's being done to churn
things
also if there is no rules are no rules
in place guiding the
judges then something probative may be
out shown by something that is harmful
to the character in general of the
person in
question well that was the original
bill then uh there are people who wish
it to go into the opposite
direction and if you've followed the
paper trail on Rules of Evidence that's
bills that have come before
us there needs to be some kind of
discretion on the part of the judge and
the Rules of Evidence in New Hampshire
are not mandatory in civil court if
you've been watching Law and Order for
21 years like I
have uh you will realize that that's
criminal
court if you've been watching Night
Court as I have been it has got nothing
to do with
courts The Rules of Evidence are
guidance and judges are given some broad
discretion the question keeps arising
how much
discretion does this particular judge
use and once again through the special
committee on the Family Division of the
Circuit
Court I believe we have some good
interest on the part of the
administrative judges that if there's a
judge that seems to be way too
permissive in letting things in and some
people object to that or a judge that's
way too restrictive to let
proferred evidence in and we have some
of that if somebody's really an outlier
this needs to come more before the
attention of the Justice Department's
Administration where again continuing
education bring us back into a good
place and I think that one of the ways
that that objective observers might see
where is a judge that is too far one way
or the other
is by the amendment that I'm suggesting
the amendment simply replaces the bill
by
saying if the court admits evidence or
testimony over the objection of one of
the
parties or if the Cho the court chooses
not to admit evidence or testimony
offered by one of the parties the court
shall note in the record the reason for
its decision in other words judge you
just can't wander around doing what you
feel like if you're going to either
accept or reject something and you're a
good judge you'll have a good reason and
you shouldn't be afraid to note it and I
think what this winds up doing is
letting the judges continue to have the
discretion that you have to have in
circuit
court but
say if you go too far this way or that
way little continuing education time
wouldn't hurt so I think this amendment
um accomplishes what many of the people
testifying before us would like to do
without putting undo restrictions on a
judge any
discussion representative Raymond thank
you Mr chairman um if we pass this um
Amendment as it is if it becomes law
will that open the door for people who
feel that they were treated unfairly to
have an Avenue for appeal if they have
something from the judge saying why they
didn't admit the evidence it will if
they object according to the proper way
to object when evidence or testimony is
proferred okay which is why again prosay
which is 80% of family
court I'm willing to bet most of them
haven't read this right because there
are rules and on when and how you make
an objection and if you don't you don't
have grounds for appeal on what you
failed to object to in a timely manner
and if on another matter a point of law
or protocol procedure you do have
grounds for objection you cannot I mean
for appeal you cannot bring in an
objection you didn't make in the initial
case the initial trial okay so assuming
that that a person the the judge makes
his decision the person says I
disagree with or I object to your
decision the judge says well I'm writing
down why based on this new law why I'm
making it at that point the person would
then have grounds for an
appeal grounds for
appeal are based on grounds for a
complaint perhaps improper understanding
or improper ruling at law and there's
something about protocols too I mean
there's two reasons you can object and
you have lots of lawyers in the family
what what are the two reasons you may
object from Circuit Court represent it
doesn't get passed on by Blood so I have
no idea but I do know based on the
testimony that we heard that this would
be
something the one of the problems that
they were having with the appeal process
is that you know they have all this
evidence and there was nothing to say um
and representative long might might be
able to help me along with this but
there was nothing for them to be able to
say like oh I had this because once you
don't have the evidence in it can't go
into an appeal but if part of it is the
judge saying I'm not going to allow this
and then he writes it down then that can
be part of from what I understand but I
am not a lawyer
so you just have Bunches of them around
you yes um it will at least
signal how many judges write how much
down because if there's a judge
that people realize okay that was fair
um even though somebody objects and the
judge writes it down
and an objective observer looks at it
and said yeah well that's right yeah the
judge was right to do that the judge was
right to do that we fine but if we get a
situation where there's too many I don't
think the judge was right to do that
says a supervising lawyer then there's
some continuing education that needs to
happen we're not opening the floodgates
this is kind of a way to say you can
object to one way or the other you have
to give the reason if you object you
have to give a reason not just it's
hurting my case not just I don't like it
but why would this piece of evidence be
inadmissible then you can argue
probative is lesser than attacking
another party you could argue that the
piece of evidence proferred is does not
enhance the case I mean there's numbers
of reasons
um and that's how this has to be based
on as those reasons and it has to be
noted representative Greg and I think
one of the things um thank you uh
chairman Pearson one of the things that
we talked about over and over that we
heard about over and over in the special
um committee which it's hard to always
remember what we talked about in there
and what we talked about in here but um
that we were hearing a lot is that there
was an overarching thing that people
weren't being heard that they felt like
they especially our post Sal it against
that they felt like they didn't so this
you know we do do not want to bog down
the judges either but for whatever
reason they're not allowing stuff in or
they are they're thinking it you know
they have something so just to write
down so that people have a true
understanding so they at least know they
were heard and because I think a lot of
what we were hearing is that people just
feel like they weren't heard like their
evidence was dismissed but the judge
does have a reason so this is just
having them log kind of what they
thought so that they have a reason to
try to um help those prosay litigants
you know a little bit more to understand
the court system it's not our job
certainly to or the judge's job to you
know give them a full law degree but
certainly in that one area where they're
already thinking it we can at least put
it in writing so they have it so I think
that was kind of part of the thought
process on that the issue of Rules of
Evidence was one of the four major
topics in the special committee and I
picked to be the committee subcommittee
of five looking at evidence the five of
us who are on both committees so that
we've already done this at some length
um
and we were also the study
committee out of this committee to look
at it so anything else anybody else on
Rules of Evidence
this okay seeing no
hands up the motion before us is
amendment
24 on House Bill 475 moved by The Chair
seconded by the Vice chair with the
clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative disimon yes
representative bfid yes representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina will be voting yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Molton yes
representative Raymond yes
1620 and now the motion before us is for
house bill for
475a with the amendment
2023-24 H and I will make the motion
ought to pass as amended and a second
second okay okay representative Vice
chairman long seconds any further
discussion this is now the
bill
seeing no further discussion when the
clerk is ready please call the role
chairman Pearson yes representative long
yes representative ton yes
representative bfid representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Petr will be voting yes representative
Perez representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond yes 16 to
zero any objection to
consent seeing none on to consent and if
I can have the form I will fill out the
blurb this concludes the exact session
on House Bill
475 thank
you and now we open the exec session on
House Bill
[Music]
499 and it is relative to the admission
of certain
evidence in Family
Court
proceedings and the
chair moves let's see are there any
amendments coming forth on this I
haven't been given any there were a few
that bounced around around a long time
ago but I don't know if anybody you know
amendments can be printed and done out
of os but they don't have to be moved
and you know usually they let me know if
somebody's going to move something and
nobody did I want to give you one more
shot at it in case if it's ready to
go uh so I guess that's going to be
a so House Bill 499 the chair moved
moves ought to excuse me the chair moves
inexpedient to
legislate I'll second and representative
long will second
it take a minute if you would to reread
the
original
bill which is
somewhere
right
all right I think you've had a shot at
reading it uh this bill requires the
court in the Family Division cases to
admit any evidence or testimony in any
form and do we mean
that once again what about the probative
evidence that should not be admitted for
good cause what about evidence that is
simply churning the process so that the
case goes out for two or three years
because there's always another motion to
admit
evidence trial court must use a
balancing test to make a determination
and again if they lean one way or the
other I've been referencing some
continuing education to help you know
you get somebody who's a real estate
lawyer I and has practiced real estate
law for 10 years gets nominated to be a
judge and gets put in Family Court I
think this committee probably knows at
least as much as that judge who's
probably going to be a good judge but is
just starting at step
one so they need the continuing educ
education and I'm very happy that
they're quite amenable to
this the bill says that it is not the
judge that will make the determination
but the
respondent in the original Bill section
Roman numeral 2 it says the court shall
apply New Hampshire Rules of
Evidence to enhance the predictable
orderly fair and reliable presentation
first of all that's kind of what we have
now secondly we've moved from the
respondent making the determination to
the court now making the determination
and which is it the bill seems to
contradict
itself research and you know I I thank
God for Wednesday Adams and all the
great work she's done for us research
has shown that there are a handful of
states that demand all evidence offered
be accepted and the Rules of Evidence
also include the various procedures in
this so so I did a little snooping in
one of the states that
allows what this bill would want and and
what I discovered is since most family
court cases have one or both parties
going prosay that is to say representing
themselves it requires those not trained
in the law or who have read this several
times to understand what all the rules
are one party seeks to admit a piece of
evidence and the other party thinks
according to the Rules of Evidence this
shouldn't happen but the judge does it
anyway
the motion must be made immediately
challenging the ruling of the judge and
reasons must be articulated as to why
the judge ER based on chapter law
Supreme Court ruling case law and
procedures if a litigant goes home and
does research or talks to someone he
understands what he or she should have
said it's too late it should have been
done at that time was that means you
kind of have to know all of this stuff
so once
again when we have a judge who seems to
be leaning to far to one side or the
other to favor men rather than woman or
the reverse or whatever or seems to
exclude too much or seems to include too
much or not too much it would be
impossible to pass a law to say exactly
how it must be done so therefore the
Judiciary amendable to the suggestion
that one or another judge seems to be
going a little bit to one way or the
other a retired judge sitting in a
courtroom where there have been a little
too many complaints made against a judge
or else what ing televised recordings of
certain hearings the Judiciary will be
willing to do some further training most
of the um papers that different ones
sent us had some variation of we
understand what he's trying to get but
we really don't think this will be
practical so again that's my my two
cents worth on Rules of Evidence anybody
else want to weigh in or did I take all
the good points in you oh all the points
good points thank you well next time I'm
gonna save some good points field okay
I'll take it I was on a roof I'm sorry
you're getting close to Perfection I am
not getting close to Perfection maybe on
rules of careful be very careful I'm
getting
close I do want to meet the judge we
spoke about I
do anybody else
the motion before us on House Bill 499
is itl move by chairman Pearson seconded
by Vice chairman long with the clerk
please call the
RO chairman Pearson
yes representative long yes
representative
disimon yes representative bford
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Melvin yes Representative
Steven Pearson yes representative grman
yes representative LC yes representative
patrin will be voting yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond
1620 any objections to
consent seeing none I'll take another
piece of paper please when you have a
minute
thank
you this ends the exact session on House
Bill
499 like to go a little bit out of order
here and take
um House
Bill
and representative Molton you have an
amendment and I'm about to pass them
around here you
go
the chair will entertain a motion on
Amendment
2023 2298 h on House Bill 618 from
representative Molton on the
amendment
yes um just to speak on this a little
bit no you're got to make a motion yes
I'm going to make a motion to first
first
to uh ought to pass that's a good thing
good very good that's it and
representative Bickford second that okay
go you sure you didn't work all last
night no this is just me in my natural
form okay um that's why she worked night
shift I know right so this was B
uh representative Bickford and I just he
educated me on just some language
cleanup on this and honestly I don't
even remember I'd have to refresh my
memory as to where it was
um but it it was literally just just
cleaning up some
words so that's all we were
doing Amendment cleans up words may I Mr
chairman yeah may speak to it better
because he was the one that language
representative big
I unfortunately I left my my uh copies
at home I guess I picked up the wrong
stuff but what it is the first section
was about extending uh
aages uh a period of reage from one
month to two months and the problem is
federal law says it has to be one month
and if we and if we don't do what the
feds tell us to do then they will uh
penalizes in 4D money which you see 21
million but and it may be only a portion
of that but uh anyway we decided not to
go down that road it just wasn't worth
the fight right now uh so that's what's
removed and the other thing that's
removed is the word divorce because they
started off by calling it divorce
hearing so we're taking out that word
that's but we did like the idea that
Health and Human Services would uh give
a form to people explaining to them how
the wage assignment works and that they
can get a w W from it there is a method
to do
that which I'm very much in favor
of if you recall the hearing
representative Spain moved this bill to
us because um there have been a few
cases where a day
late is a problem and how can we work
around sincere good faith efforts
without running a file of the law and I
think his his bill with the amendment
before us accomplishes what he wants I
don't you don't no this just informative
I he I remember he came here and said
well I didn't know anything about I
never heard of anything about I could
establish me me and Mom could establish
an account a separate account and go
through them rather than having to go
through health andher services so that's
what we're accomplishing with this that
that the knowledge would be out there uh
I think the one month may have helped
him a little bit in that
respect I think so we we I think we all
got a little lost on the other part on
the pport thing I tried to find out more
information on it they did change it
from $5,000 to $2500 not all that many
years ago but I can't I I just don't
know about the
passport representative
grman thank you chairman Pearson um I
guess this question so the Department of
Health and Human Services and the
division of child support do they
support have have you heard feedback
from them about creating this form and
whether they interesting they they never
came I did call and leave messages uh
with them and uh trying to think the
woman's name over there uh but Matt
Hayes of course takes some of the calls
and ask him to come by or let me know or
anything any any issues but nobody
showed up it was just very lonely
here
next time there's any question with
Health and Human Services relating to
any member of this committee um talk to
the chairman of the Health and Human
Services oversight committee and I will
be very happy to call them on your
behalf the chairman of the over
uh oh
oh so yeah I mean they're they're
underst staffed by about 250 people over
there they tell us so
if this serves to be a problem just just
let me know there I'm trying to the
woman's name over there that uh I'm
sorry I I escaped me but his boss and
she's incredibly responsive to my calls
such but still okay did I see a hand way
down in the corner representative
Raymond you know we really do need to
get you a styrofoam that's what I think
I need you know one of those fingers
yeah yeah all right put it on your
Christmas list very professional looking
I think um so this one I'm confused by
this because my notes from the last time
we heard this um showed that um Child
Support Services did come it was two
individuals and their concern with this
bill was about who makes the form and
they were saying that like my notes were
child support can't make a a form for
the judicial branch so the judicial the
court system has to make their own forms
and so that was my my note from the last
time
um and so I'm reluctant to pass
something having child support make a
form for the judicial branch if that is
not the
appropriate um vehicle to do that
although I'm in support of a form I
think a form would be helpful I just
think that it's
usually the judge the uh court system
that does that well you have child
support referees today I believe and
child support pretty much controls that
so I uh that's interesting I that it
would require court and I can't read my
own chicken scratch about people's names
so I
apologize
okay anybody else we could always take
out the
um who makes the form just say I was
questioned using the standard well the
word standard even needed to be in there
but I was out
quoted
further
discussion representative long uh thank
you Mr chairman um so in essence I this
really isn't a form it's more of a
uh piece of liter literature explaining
what it is yeah so it's not really a
form um but I because I I have the same
notes has representative Raymond had
that uh Division of Child Support
Services Health and Human Services said
that the court system should be making
forms but it's not really a form that
you would fill out it's it's just
a pamplet information pamphlet telling
you well we could certainly take that
out I think we have time enough to well
if you look at lines 14 156 that seems
to Define what the form is I I don't
have in front of me it's in the
amendment which should have even have
that
uh was passed out we got one right there
coming Mr CH Mr chairman I'm at the end
of the trail who's so it would have to
be representative Molton thank you
you're welcome um it would have to be a
form that it that they fill out because
it says in on line 15 allowing for both
parties to detail their preferred form
of payment all right that's
true so the question is whether DHHS
makes the form is that your question
representative Bickford no that was uh
represent Raymond's question I or yeah
that is the question right now that is
the question um I I think it would be
how Serv because they they're the ones
that sit down with a party and talk to
them about what it's going to be and if
they don't like it then they go to then
you go to court on it you're you're
under the context of court but
you're that's my understanding they have
child sport referees that you go to
before you go into court and this way
this would show
up who wants to speak representative
Raymond Raymond thank you Mr chairman
but the but the bill
says this form is for the hearing at the
final hearing so like this the bill
doesn't talk about what happens at child
support before court happens right
because that's child support this bill
talks about um at the final hearing
that's when this form will be thing
thing so it's already been it's actually
the word is supposed to be prior to they
they left that out uh final hearing oh
okay you recall that that we
said huh do you have a copy
of when you're when you wrote it I
didn't tell them to do that no I only
did the things you saw me fill out the
email that I sent to OS yeah I thought
we put in Prior does anybody have a copy
of the original Bill handy it's on the
website bu at the final in a way
supposed to be before the final hearing
or at
least could the original bill doesn't
say that either so no that's something
we uh we added I believe yeah the
original bill on online on legis scan
says at the final hearing as well at the
final divorce hearing and you struck
divorce right but it still says at the
final hearing I guess I'm just we we
struck the word divorce because not all
not all child support hearings have to
do with divorce no that's totally
appropriate I agree completely and I
agree a form should happen I'm just
right and the original bill it does have
at the end DHHS Division of Child
Support Services shall develop a
standard form to be presented at the
final strike out the word divorce
hearing so the the the
dhs's role in developing a
form um is uh constant all the way
through this process whether it's
correct or not is another
question yeah they
they it should have been before by the
final
hearing because that was his concern he
says nobody ever told me anything
anywhere during my my uh was the sub
committee divorce I guess it was when we
met Mr chairman yes yeah may I yes thank
you I I'm Wonder wondering if um
Department of Health and Human Services
is the right vehicle for this form child
support forms are filled out in
court not at DHHS the final disposition
from the court in so far as garnishment
of wages or private pay W um child
support comes from the court to DHHS so
I'm wondering if this particular form in
which we speak should be this verbiage
should be added to the child support
calculation
form or an addendum to as opposed to a
form that DHHS would have to develop
themselves so D Simone yes sorry the
chair would like to suggest we uh put a
hold on this hearing and then then we do
some research and call over to
dhs's Children's people thingy and see
what they say about this and put a few
phone calls out and we'll come back to
this so we're going to uh um I want to
use the correct term not do this anymore
a recess a recess thank
you all right so we're recessing
and I don't
it's no we're just
recessing we're not doing anything in
terms of determination we're just
putting it on the side so we can do some
little bit of research here and would
the committee uh
researcher
you would you
call the relevant division within
DHHS who deals with children's
things and ask them please the question
that we have been discussing are they
the appropriate party to um to do this
what we've been
discussing that's the name of get you
the name of the PE
uh representative Bickford for a
contact uh
bigford bford brist yes I did thank you
yes sus Susan brisen B r i SS o n she's
do you have a number that you can pass
along to somebody I think so okay she's
not in
my it's
not
yeah
um want me do right
now in my
office oh we'll take a I believe
transpar I just believe in transparency
that's
all oh thank
you
wonders what we're doing we're not doing
really much of anything because we're
having a recess for five
minutes
e
so everybody
gather and this is the Trail of phone
numbers that led to this one to that one
to this one to that one to this
one
no
problem
I just spoke to one number that referred
me to another number that referred me to
a third number that referred me to a
fourth number that referred me to
attorney Susan
bristen who is attorney with the
Division of Child Support
Services yeah me
too how is our friend Susan
doing it's not that I don't trust you
it's just you've been in this place long
enough to get a direct
line and our mutual answer from the
attorney is she doesn't think that the
department is the agency that will do
this he thinks it's the courts as a wise
man recently once said before all of
this transpired
right you told me
that I didn't hear well put your mic on
and thank you
huh what did the counselor tell
you counselor told me that she thought
it should be the court because not
everybody comes before the child support
officer or referee would you believe she
just told me the same thing that's good
I I love consistency well at least we're
coming into consensus so what does it do
to the
amendment she also said that on the
unified child support
uh form that number seven talks about
wage assignment whether you wanted to
wage assignment uh no not why you want
to but there is a wage assignment then
number eight says do you want to suspend
wage
assignment good as uh representative
ball pointed out well maybe somebody
thinks that's not to pay child support
but um anyway that
representative Spain came to us and said
well I never knew about it I was unaware
that's why he felt that something should
be enumerated to explain um more about
it anyway it would appear that
representative Spain is not the close
friend with attorney Susan that you and
I are I I actually don't know Mr we know
her more than representative Spain us
probably yeah
yeah so um committee here we are what
let's just have an informal little
chitchat before we go forward as to what
we might do going forward anybody want
to pipe
in representative Molton well it sounds
like we should go to the office of
legislative services and get this
changed to what that to say that the
court should develop the form and uh
that they should put it in as an amendm
to the child support calculation form
because as as representative D Simone
and I were mentioning the lawyers have
access to the child support calculation
form so if if we make this as an
amendment to the child support AC uh
calculation form then the lawyers would
have access to it and then because there
are some cases that get resolved outside
of court so if that's the case with the
lawyers then then they can have access
to the
form how does that sound to
everybody because just that in writing
what you just said yeah
well we're going to break for lunch a
little bit and would you like to trot
over to OSS and see if they can crank
out of 30 minute specials when we come
back she there was another thing that
she said that should be a uh it should
be presented at the temporary not the
final which is the very first
hearing yeah
um it is line 12 in your Amendment yeah
change the word final to
Temp yeah and we questioned about the
word
form it is that was okay because they
the parties have to fill out information
we mentioned that before because they
have to put in that what their preferred
for form of payment is so the parties do
have to impart information so therefore
it is a
form
she did caution me about looking at
the uniform
support order form and if that is
sufficient enough but that's the one
that says
suspend in other words it could be ented
in that area if we had wanted it instead
of having several pieces of pay
for I would say maybe we should do it as
an as a as an addendum because some of
it is
just thank you some of it is just
information that the other party is
given but the only part is that they
just have to put in what their preferred
form of payment is so we should have it
completely separate from the child
support
calculation okay that's okay with me
anybody else want to input and I've
given you the
attorney's private line number so um I
wrote it out because I don't want it to
be P made public and um so after we
break for
lunch um you can see what you can come
up with and we'll look at it as the last
item of business so there it is I want
to do one more for just to maintain our
record of
speed
open the hearing on Senate Bill 253
Senate Bill parental access to minor
child's medical records is there an
amendment that is to be brought forth I
don't think so but just
checking if if there were you'd know it
one of you would know
it the chair recog seeing none the chair
recognizes representative patrino for a
motion
thank you Mr chairman I make a motion to
itl Senate Bill 253 and I second it
speak to your motion please yes upon uh
looking carefully at this
U proposal uh the issue really isn't a
matter of parents having access to their
minor child's medical records it really
seems to be a matter of uh access to the
patient portal after the age of uh 12 it
really is an issue of uh the software
which makes it impossible to isolate
certain information in accordance with
federal and state laws so really this is
not a matter of legislation it can only
be resolved um if and when uh the
technology advances accordingly so uh
other than that parents do have access
to their minor child's medical records
except with this difficulty concerning
the patient portal so we recommend itl
anyone else to speak to this uh
representative kofalt who was the Prime
sponsor of this suggested we itl it
there was a vehicle over at um what's
the name of that committee Health and
Human Services that's right how soon
they forget uh HB 406 and they'll be
taking a different kind of stab at it
but the prime sponsor when this came
over to us from the Senate um was
representative kofalt and he he seconds
the itl idea anyone else
all
right the motion before us is Senate
Bill 253 parental access to minor
child's medical records no amendments
representative patrino moved itl the
chairman uh second it with the clerk
please call the
role the deputy clerk please call the
role let the no I'm sorry I just I did
not pick up on who you said made the
second to write it down thank you
chairman
Pearson chairman
Pearson
yes Vice chairman long
yes representative deimon
yes representative
Bickford representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative long La ball I can't even
say my name sorry um is a yes
representative Melvin yes Representative
Steven Pearson yes representative grman
yes representative
LC representative Patrina yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg
yes representative
Molton rep representative Raymond
yes that's 16 yes zero no any objection
to
consent and the clerk will write out the
committee report and all of you writing
out committee reports the protocol as
they go to me and then I look at them
and think how wonderful they are and
then I pass them on to the clerk so
those of you who have a writing project
it first comes to me and this ends the
exact session Senate Bill 253 I have a
feeling that
535 requiring an attorney for a child
who's the subject of a proceeding in a
family case going to take a little while
do you you think so it's a slam D or
what what do you
think I'm not sure well we're gonna have
to give
representative oh she's go is she you
so
seems like the consensus is uh we are
going to go on this little next one
thing here and representative Molton
would you mind going down to OSS now and
we can just stretch it out a little bit
you know don't don't make them sit down
and chat with you you know how they get
but come back as soon as you can and
I'll I'll defer a vote until you're back
okay if you want to run off with that
thank you so much I think that'll work
and bring back food if you find
any wow and nice
handwritings peners ship
yeah open the hearing on House Bill
535 which is basically lawyers for
kids and I do see an
amendment representative uh long would
you wish to speak move your amendment I
would I uh I move all to pass on uh
Amendment 2023 2356
H and is there a republican who might
like to go by the name representative
ball there is for a second thank you
please speak to your Amendment
representative long Vice chairman thank
you Mr chairman
um so we uh this committee met a couple
times uh we had four or five hours into
this and determined that uh there were
two amendments that were recommended to
us from members of the
public uh one was from uh court
appointed special Advocates and the
other was re um the other one was
recommended by a u contingent of uh five
or six non
profits and through timely um discussion
we decided
that um to come up with this this
amendment
um this amendment requires an
appointment of
council for be considered for um for
youth that
are
um that are going to placement or that
have the likelihood of going into
placement
um it gives two days for the Department
to notify the court within two business
stes of such
placement and it also um it also
changes the
um
the foster care Bill of Rights to add
this requirement of
council uh which is the only Avenue with
way which with which a foster foster
parent would know that this is their
right
oh well you guys need
copies yeah these guys got
it that was half right this side got it
that's what happens when you oh leaning
to the right representative long I
see yeah I made sure of people to my
right or
all
that's everybody
got need another
one put one in
her
yeah you you should have got it
earlier got
it and the chair we recognizes Vice
chairman long for a doover on walking us
through what we have before us so so the
um uh what I what I could add is the uh
it's it's the express interest of the
child this this attorney would be apped
uh would be appointed for
um and I think those two explanations is
all that was needed andless somebody has
questions now this replaces the entire
bill it's one of those everything after
the enacting Clause so the bill is um
should we pass the amendment what we
have here in the amendment yeah in the
amendment the amendment all
right any questions representative
long
representative
ball put into drafting this amendment um
it was worked on by the juvenile right
policy group way point New Hampshire
legal assistance disabilities rights
Center New Hampshire the children's Law
Center New Hampshire new Futures and the
ACL VI of New Hampshire it also is
supported by the state agency the office
of child ADV
also support amendment I would just like
The Usual Suspects wow
fantastic any further
questions representative
Bickford
let's take that one up because it's in
boldface italics which means it is a
change which means it's an intentional
change so let me ask uh those of you who
worked most particularly on this to um
speak to the word
expressed so yes representative long
thank you Mr chairman so the attorney
that's uh the attorney that's appointed
is the expressed uh concern of the
child so that
attorney would take up not the best
interest of the child but what the what
the child expressly would
want so that that this attorney would
represent the child's um expressed
interest not best interest there are
other people representing the best
interest of the child
by expressed do you mean articulated
spoken aloud because it has two meanings
yeah if if okay and if the child doesn't
Express right the attorney doesn't do it
correct if I'm if I if I'm the child and
I want to live with my drug addicted
mother that's my expressed interest to
live with my
mother and that attorney will
have that best interest that
expressed interest in in what the
child's looking
for I mean that examples is a little
over the
top
correct
yeah no no they they they get they get
an appointed attorney that attorney will
represent the express interest of the
child anything further on the word
expressed because it has two or three
definitions what if the child doesn't
Express anything can the attorney lead
the child by making
suggestions I don't
know what an attorney would do or
wouldn't do um if the child doesn't have
any Express I I don't see a child not
weighing in on
anything so I I I don't see a child not
having any expressed interest I mean
they're going to want to go back with
mom or dad or grandma or somebody
there's something or I don't want to be
in this home I'm
in
so yeah I don't I don't see that anybody
else on the word expressed uh
representative Raymond was
flexing and
okay I I don't see your hand now so
thank you um all right if we've killed
that one anything else on the bill in
general let's let's look at other
questions to excuse me the
amendment okay now representative
Raymond
it is
yes
ORS
ATT yeah we yeah yeah we we wouldn't put
that in language I mean you know an
attorney getting paid to represent
somebody I would hope they'd want to go
visit
them um you know that that's an
assumption I think that we we assume
that you know
that that a that an attorney
representing a child would go to court
and say I haven't visited the child um I
I don't see that happen is there
anything that would prohibit the judge
from
um assigning a different attorney or
reassigning attorney if it comes to
light that the attorney for whatever
reason hasn't been making those regular
visits um I'm asking because I Come From
New York where I worked in the family
court system there and frequently
attorneys became overburdened and we'd
have attorneys that met with the child
for five minutes before the court case
um and it just it wasn't effective
representation um and so I
I I worry about um that circumstance
happening here okay I mean I I could I
could only see I could only see that
happening if if if there's a uh
um I mean if an attorney's appointed and
they're not visiting a child so they
don't have any idea of the expressed
interest of the child I would think
they'd want to step down and tell the
judge I'd like to resign myself from
this because I don't have the time to
visit the child um and and then the
judge would appoint somebody else uh but
to say I still want to be the attorney
although I'm not going to visit the
child you know I don't see any attorney
doing that I would
hope representative
B thank you Vice chair um correct me if
I'm wrong but I believe we had this
discussion um and what it was said to us
is if the if the attorneys know that
there is work for them then the
attorneys will be trained to do this
work and they will be available so this
would actually increase the number of
attorneys willing to do this hard work
right yeah we that's a very good point
we're also told that there are attorneys
that are interested in children uh
representing children so it wouldn't be
looking for people that that they're
they're already
interested anyone
else Pro
con no
idea uh let let let me ask this question
I I can do that um if this is going to
be a tight vote I would like oh you're
back they um they're working on it on an
ASAP basis but I didn't have to stick
around while they do that they're going
to email it to me and you and the house
committee services and they'll make
they'll make some copies and correct run
it down thank you everybody here make
sure okay then the did you did we make a
motion on this already uh we made we
already made a motion we did yes I even
can have that right here long and ball
so the uh motion before us
is
yeah please go ahead we got to get you a
big
thingy
yeah
so I'll just be loud oh there it goes
all right so anyways at The Advisory
Board they were saying it would have
been helpful to some of our kids who are
appoint who are placed out of state to
have an attorney to represent them um
and I won't I won't go into details CU
there were things on the news um but
that seemed to be something that um The
Advisory Board board was
recommending representative
Nelson um regard uh thank you Mr
chairman
um is it okay for me to say that there
might be something down the line that
would address representative Raymond's
concern it's okay for you to ask that
yeah um I think think there might be
something in that's going to be um
presented in legislation this session
that might address some of those
issues okay any hidden hands there is a
Hidden Hand we got to do a round table
next time representative Grossman thank
you chairman Pearson just to piggyback
on that I think that's one of the most
important carve outs in this amendment
is for those children that are possibly
being placed in a group home or Child
Care institution out of the states that
they have voice and
representation um so in terms of this
amendment that's one of the key points
why I'm supporting it um thank
you there is a um
bill that was given to me by the child
advocate right after the big stink show
in Tennessee broke into the public and
they did it on the on the the very
quick um like just about when Bill
filing season was over and what I've
done is because I really wanted Buy in
by at least the
Departments uh dcyf and also the
children's services at
DHHS as well as office of child advocate
I took the language that was given to me
by the child
advocate and got it over to the two
agencies at the Department of Health and
Human Services and I asked them to work
together to come up with language they
could both be happy with all all three
groups could be happy with and um
they're really working very hard on that
I've signed off solo really on the
original bill that Cassandra gave to uh
me simply because I had to I had a
deadline but we hope that by the final
sign off we will have that
consensus language and whether we do or
not of course that bill would most
likely come to us uh next January
February at which point we can amend it
to make it exact L better than it has
been along the way
so so there's stuff in the pipeline I
don't know if that's what you were
referring to but yes it was um Mr
chairman I just didn't know if it was
Germaine to our conversation right now
so that's why I was I well if it's not
Germaine just forget everything I just
say okay yes uh representative
Molton thank you Mr chairman I'm just
wondering who is paying for the attorney
representation for the
child that's not our
St we're the policy committee I'm not
sure who's going to pay and it'll go to
finance so this is going to just just to
clarify my understanding I'm not
contentious about it or anything I'm
just curious so because this is it
sounds like there's a lot of different
types of children that would be served
by this amendment so so some of them are
going to be foster some of them are
going to be you know in group homes it
says some of them are going to be in
institutions and maybe some of them are
private so so I is that just based on
the judge's discretion who pays for it
or that's why that's why I just don't
know it doesn't
say yeah and there's no fiscal note and
it's not a late Bill well there is a
fiscal note yeah oh there is on the
original one what does it
say is there
yes
where this is the amendment I don't see
a fiscal note on the
amendment yeah it's our friend the
indeterminable
amount so I mean I really think somebody
else is going to have to worry about
this and not
US Representative
ball when we um talked about this we did
have representatives and uh Vice chair
long maybe could refresh my memory but
we had them and they came from either
the finance committee or from the
Judiciary but not from the and they came
and they spoke to it and said if we
don't pass this it will not be put into
the budget if we pass it it will be and
that we can't do it on speculation and
they were actually pretty much in
support of it from what I was told and I
also just want to remind I didn't know
about anything else coming um down the
pipeline but just to remind you that we
do have six um groups that represent the
juvenile rights policy group as well as
the state agency of the office of the
child advocate that put this particular
version together and is in support of
it anyone
else thank you representative balette
that answered my
question this is about 90% of what I
would like and I don't want the 10% that
isn't to be the enemy of the 90% that is
so I'm going to take the win I think
when I vote and then when we discover
there needs to be some changes we can do
that that's just me anybody
else all right the motion before us is
Amendment 20
23-23 56h amendment to House Bill 5 35
FN and I had to ask is there a fiscal
note well just read the title mark and
um the motion was made ought to pass on
the amendment by representative ball
with a second excuse me representative
long uh with representative ball
seconding it uh the clerk a clerk may
call the role please chairman Pearson
yes Vice chairman long yes
representative D Simon yes
representative Bickford
no representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Melvin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LC yes representative
Patrina yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Molton yes representative Raymond
yes 15 yes one no the amendment the
amendment
passes and uh now a motion is in order
for the bill as amended and the chair
recognizes
representative
long and for a motion I'll move uh House
Bill 5 35 uh ought to pass as
amended and a second from the our side
of the playground thank
you and um any further discussion
because this is what we just adopted as
the amendment is the bill but your
second chance at it if you
want yes representative Bickford I'll
just reiterate my my concern which is
the the word expressed and I feel that
that limits the court and now it's wide
open for the court to do what they want
and so that's I don't want to limit the
court in this case so that'll be my
reasoning for voting no one okay
appreciate thank
you any further discussion
representative
Molton thank you Mr chairman um so that
that would imply that the child is the
one doing the expression or the attorney
on their behalf
so so you know they're they they
can't unless unless unless a in sorry
unless an interest of the child is
implied because they are too young to
speak otherwise the kid kids are very
good at at letting you know what they're
what they want so whether or not it's
feasible is another thing but but kids
are good at letting you know what they
want well you know that sorry so in in
response if I may I I just don't agree
that that much I want the court to be
able to ask whatever they want of the
attorney that's representing the child
and this says uhuh if a child can't
represent can't express them then they
they're ignored and I that's my concern
that's my point is that it they're
speaking by like Age Two so and then
other than that they just need to be
like fed and clothed and housed and
things like that and love that's not
good enough for
me okay well representative long H yeah
thank you Mr chairman um yeah I'm not
getting where you're confused with the
express it's the attorney is for what
the child expresses not the best
interest of the child it's what the
child expresses and that's the attorney
so where is the issue with the court not
having leeway to do
what uh my my concern is that the child
may not be able to express themself and
it's not unusual for a disabilities
child or whatever to need to have the
job judge of the court to be able to say
I want you to represent this child
ex the broad spectrum of the child not
just what the child expresses or cannot
express is unable to express I want the
court to have uh the broad picture of
what they want to get they know what
they want I don't but that's current
that's what happens currently yes and
what this adds is not only does that
happen but will also the court will also
know what the child expresses I don't
see that I just see that it has to be
expressed that's how I read
it he said he
said okay okay representative
ball since you mentioned the special
education and what I'm thinking is even
a nonverbal child can express themselves
through pictures um through use of dolls
through there are many ways to do it and
I believe what is trying to say is that
the attorney can't stand up there and
say what the attorney thinks but he must
represent the expressed interest how
they get that to express whether the
attorney has to hire an interpreter
because the child is deaf or a sign
language or whatever it is that the
attorney is there specifically to
represents the child's interests and not
to represent anyone else's or his own
personal viewpoints is how I'm reading
it I thank you yeah I I still see it as
a limitation on the
court I like the old language better so
anyway I'm The
Loner seeing no further
discussion the motion before
us is House Bill 535 amended by
Amendment
d235 6 moved by representative
seconded by representative ball would
one of the clerks call the role please
thank you chairman Pearson yes Vice
chairman long yes representative deimon
yes representative
Bickford representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
melin yes Representative Steven Pearson
yes representative grman yes
representative LEC yes representative
Pino yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative
Molton representative Raymond yes that
is 15 to zero no 15 to one I'm so sorry
I wrote it down and said it
wrong any objection to consent
representative this fin
answer this will be a finance included
so we probably should be on regular
account all right let's put it
well it's in determinant and it wasn't
an early bill but it's an F so fin it's
that all right um well then let's leave
it off consent and have it go to regular
calendar so representative long if you
would write the blur give it to me I'll
give it to the clerk
um so this ends the um House Bill 535
live executive session and we've got a
few
things
[Music]
um going on in real time thank you very
much uh we had a question of um whether
the amendment on 68 was
Germaine I asked the uh committee
researcher can this be shot up to the
clerk of the house ASAP and she said we
already I already did it you
know uh I mean wow speaker will review
it it could be ruled non Germain on the
floor so back to opening back up do we
have the amendment in hand yet
no so we voted on the old one but then
we wanted to change it OS is currently
changing it and they will email you me
and uh the chairman all once it's ready
so they just need some time to draft it
and then we're all going to get an email
around the same time I do not currently
have the
email right and they're drafting it
right now OS is drafting it presently
and giving it a
number
this
is okay thank
you yeah there
go
okay once we're turn loose for lunch
it'll be 45 minutes minimum to get
everybody back and if they got ASAP on
this and um Wednesday is upstairs on the
fourth floor I think uh we'll have some
Expedition on
this if any anybody else has a committee
report to write this would be a great
time to work on
it did you get this
majority
um thank
you well see
that's
and there would you happen to have uh
tuna noodle casserole or uh chicken
cordum
blur uh sorry too much
sugar
consent to us preceding when we feel
like
it
e
thank
you hello uh Wednesday Adams please
uh the natives are getting restless here
and they're just wondering where we may
see hard copy of the uh latest Amendment
um I would not have access to it unless
did you send it to me did you have did
that go to Christina D or representative
Molton she is sending it
to she thought she did she's
double-checking and she will send it
to the fourth
floor uh she could send to me I'm
actually on the third flooor and I will
it's going to the third floor now to you
yes I will bring you copies thank you I
can hold them in OB bance for a few
minutes wonderful good I'll be there got
it
and now the moment you've been waiting
for we are now back into the exec
session on House Bill
618 and representative Molton has an
amendment and we have it in written form
it's always good to have paper and Pen
when the North Koreans fry the grid and
the email all goes away yes yes so
representative Molton would would you
like to present this amendment to us
please so this amendment did what we
just would you like to present it and
not yet explain
it oh something I
said we're doing formalities that's all
so I have an amendment uh that we just
drafted it is amendment
2398 and you're making a motion making a
motion to adopt this
amendment that's OT and could we have
somebody a from not yet this is just the
A and okay wait I'm being I'm being
taught here I know um I am I would like
to move to OTP amendment number 23
2023 2398 h on house on House Bill 618
FN
excuse me pardon me everybody 96 that
that includes
you I was cut
off we have a motion on the floor my
Deputy clerk says uh which we had some
problems with would the Mover and
seconder of the amendment
withdraw prev of that previous Amendment
not the one we're just doing would
that's a question who who moved it oh
I'm
sorry I'm sorry chairman peon um it was
me yeah representative Molton had put
forward a motion and it was seconded by
um representative Bickford correct we
would like to move remove would you
withdraw that amendment I would like to
make a motion to withdraw that amend
withdraw okay now we can go now that
speech that you just gave you get a
second shot again the same thing
excellent that's how you learn but
through repetition so I would like to
make a motion to
OTP Amendment
2396 h on House Bill 618 FN pretty good
she's good oh sorry and seconded I'd
like a republican to second that please
to keep our bipartisan deimon that seems
appropriate since this was mostly this
was mostly the recommendations of
Representative D Simone and well it's
true um be because of our Collective
efforts to figure out how this is would
would actually work so that we're not
held up by semantics so what this
amendment is doing is having the courts
develop the form because that's what
we've came to find out is appropriate
and we are going to have it be presented
prior to the temporary hearing because
that is what we collectively thought
would be the best
process so that's what we
did any further
discussion you know we did this in uh
Health and Human Services all the time
we do it in real time during which is
why we the best Committee in the house
and you keep pushing us along to at
least tie Health and Human Services as
best committee and this this just
enhances that so thank you cuz we're all
awesome that's why yeah we can tie with
them all right uh any further discussion
are we ready for the motion on
Amendment
2023-24 on House Bill 618 FN uh moved by
representative Molton seconded by
representative D Simon would one of the
clerks call a rooll please chairman
Pearson yes Vice chairman
long he sends his regrets sorry
representative
deimon yes representative
Bickford no actually you may
not thank you representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball
yes
representative Melvin yes yes
Representative Steven
Pearson yes representative Gman
yes representative LC is not here
representative Patrina
yes representative
Perez
yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton
yes representative Raymond
yes that is 14 yes zero no and two no
votes now just again continuing
education for those of you in your first
term why may this not go on
consent because it has a an FN no not
because of it's a fiscal note
why because it's an amendment it's not
the
bill yeah
trick question trick that was an extra
credit
question now uh the chair will entertain
a motion on the bill as
amended otpa I would like to move that
this be OTP as amended a otpa on what on
House Bill 618 FN amended with amendment
number
2023 2396 H well done a second
representative D Simon you know I never
knew how to pronounce your name until I
met the gentleman to my left Italian to
the my grandmother's made a
name any further
discussion now you are in order
sir um I'm concerned with the the word
prior to the temporary hearing
no it was prior to the final hearing
which the Susan Bron said have it done
at the temporary because I'm not sure
what comes prior to Temporary but maybe
someone else does
here I can help with that who who can
help representative Molton for a help so
I don't know
that let me just gather my thoughts um I
don't know that that is necessarily a
problem with saying prior to because
that can I I
don't let me gather my
thoughts things are only problematic if
you bring them to the court saying like
oh my God they didn't follow this policy
right if the lawyers have the the whole
reason why we wanted it to be
the uh addendum to the child support
calculators because the lawyers put that
together prior to the temporary hearing
and then you give it to the other side
and they you know they have the same
mechanism for um for calculating as well
and and ideally they should come up with
the same numbers and the what the
parties are doing is that they're imp
what this bill is doing is the parties
are just implementing what do they want
as a payment option so do they want a
check in the mail do they want it vend
mode do they want it direct deposited do
they want it cash in nickels like they
they can say how they want it and
I if they did it at the works I'm good
with it if they did it at the the the
thing is that if someone is
prosay then the court is directing them
and like here's all your papers and
they're going to get like a packet of
papers and then they can just fill it
out at the same time as they're filling
out all their other papers so the
Court's just going to give them the
papers okay and I think if they appeared
at the temporary hearing with it and
didn't give it prior to I don't
necessarily think it's going to be a
problem because it's only a problem if
it gets escalated to the judge and the
judge thinks it's so much of a problem
that they have to rule
against so if if the prior two versus at
the temporary hearing I don't
necessarily think that that's a problem
only for someone who wants to really
nitpick and a judge that's willing to to
rule in their
favor
anything further on
otpa motion before
us call the
question the motion before is a to pass
as
amended on House Bill 618 FN as amended
by 2023
2396 H mooved by representative Molton
and seconded by representative D
Simone and would a clerk please call the
role chairman Pearson
yes representative deimon yes
representative Bickford yes
representative Nelson
yes representative McMahon
yes representative ball yes
representative Melvin yes Representative
Steven Pearson yes representative grman
yes
representative LC is not here
representative patrio
yes representative
Perez yes representative Greg yes
representative Molton yes representative
Raymond yes that's 14 yay zero nay and
two no
votes I have no objection to it going on
consent unless it is is not allowed to
you know some of these FNS that are
vague I don't think disqualify it but
any objection
otherwise no good okay we are finished
with the exec session on House Bill
618 and thank you everybody for our
first year together and it's only going
to get better because we've been trying
you know what thank you
everybody and get those reports into the
clerk
I just gave you a and say hi to Milford
sorry about the
parade
well Maria go on the oval can go on the
town go on the town camera looking
down
thank oh that's right I this is what I
want
okay